unhcr submission is that the
flight on 14 june to rwanda should not
proceed
and more generally removals to rwanda
under the agreement between the uk
and rwanda
should be suspended
the reason for this position most
relevant to these interim relief
proceedings is the unhcr serious
concerns about rwanda's capacity to make
fair refugee status determination
decisions adequate to protect
from indirect refuulemon
in its written submissions the unhcr
draws the court's attention to a number
of relevant factual matters
mr binsky highlights the vast majority
of the rwandan government's decision
making on refugee claims has been of a
prima facie kind
concerning objective circumstances in a
limited number of nearby countries of
origin
and that case-by-case determination
is nascent
there is said to be
only one eligibility officer in rwanda
assessing
all such claims
mr binsky also highlights that when the
secretary of state and the unhcr met in
kigali in march 2022
the unhcr was not informed that the uk
government was contemplating a process
of removing asylum seekers to rwanda
and therefore did not elicit the unhcr's
views on this proposal
further the secretary of state then
omitted from the published policy
documents
concerns which the unhcr had raised
about the proposals in meetings held in
the uk and kigali in april 2022
the substance of those concerns are set
out at paragraphs 14 and 15
of
the unhcr's written submissions before
this call
mr binsky also highlights that the unhcr
has subsequently become aware
of decision letters issued by the
secretary of state which contained
incorrect statements about the unhcr's
involvement in the agreement with rwanda
its role in oversight
and claims that the unhcr had not
expressed substantial concerns
addressing the first round of appeal mr
binsky reiterates its submissions made
before the judge
that the unhcr warns that there is a
real risk of indirect refulemon if
asylum seekers are removed
from the uk to rwanda
the unhcr has concerns about the
fairness and capacity of the refugee
status determination process
which cannot be rectified at speed
mr binsky also submits the person's
relocated surrender may be at risk of
detention and treatment not in
accordance with international standards
should they protest against their
conditions after arrival
having identified that there were
serious issues to be tried the judge
went on to consider the balance of
justice question
that is the critical question on which
the present case turned
as we have said in our view the judge
conducted that balancing exercise in a
way that cannot be impugned by this
court on appeal
we consider
that on analysis the principal ground of
appeal before us is indeed round two
the starting point for his assessment
was that the interim period would be
relatively short about six or seven
weeks until around the end of july he
was right to take that view
we do not accept the submission that the
judge was obliged to take into account
the possibility of appeals and further
delay after the judgment of the high
court has been given
after the substantive hearing
the hypothesis for the appellant's case
must be
that they will succeed
at the substantive hearing
on that basis as the judge noted the
individual claimant would on his own
case be entitled to be returned to the
uk
if there were then an appeal as the
judge observed it would be a matter for
the appellate court to determine what
the next step should be
for example whether any interim relief
should be granted pending an appeal
given therefore that the interim period
would be relatively short
the judge was entitled to take the view
that it was unlikely that the individual
claimants before him would be improperly
returned to another state by the rwandan
authorities in that time frame
to suggest otherwise is indeed as the
judge noted speculative
furthermore in that context the judge
was entitled to give weight to the mou
and note that
they may not be legally enforceable
even as a matter of international law
but they are formal agreements between
sovereign states
the uk will expect rwanda to comply with
them and the abandoned authorities will
know that their conduct will be under
scrutiny in the particular context of
people who have been removed there by
the uk pursuant to the arrangements
between the two countries the judge did
not need to be sure as has been
submitted that the mou would be
implemented this was something to which
he was entitled to give weight and as mr
dunlop reminded us questions of weight
are not for this court on an appeal in
cases such as this
we return to the fundamental point in
this case which turns on how the judge
dealt with the balance of convenience
in our judgment he conducted that
balancing exercise properly
he did not uh in principle in the
approach which he took
he weighed all the relevant factors on
each side of the balance
he reached a conclusion which he was
reasonably entitled to reach
on the material before him
this court cannot therefore interfere
with that conclusion
and the final heading is conclusion
for the reasons he have given
this appeal is dismissed
is there anything else um
my lord my lady with uh great dividends
uh i have an application for permission
to appeal uh well there you have it lord
justice singh at the court of appeal
refusing to grant that injunction
halting a tuesday's planned deportation
flight of migrants from the uk to rwanda
the appeal has been dismissed